يستعد الرئيس بايدن
للاحتفال بالذكرى العشرين
لهجمات 11 سبتمبر من خلال زيارة كل موقع
من المواقع التذكارية يوم السبت المقبل ، حيث
أعلن البيت الأبيض عن خطط
للرئيس والسيدة الأولى لزيارة
النصب التذكاري 9 11 في مدينة نيويورك بالإضافة إلى
سانكسفيل بنسلفانيا و
البنتاغون الآن يأتي هذا بعد أن
وقع الرئيس بايدن أمرًا تنفيذيًا
يوجه وزارة العدل
لإجراء مراجعة لرفع السرية عن الوثائق
المتعلقة بالتحقيقات في هجمات 11
سبتمبر الإرهابية التي كان الرئيس
يواجه بعض الضغط من العائلات
والناجين من هجوم 11 سبتمبر
الإفراج عن هذه الوثائق ، فقد أرسلوا
خطابًا إلى الرئيس سابقًا
يقولون فيه إنه إذا لم يتخذ خطوات
للإفراج عن هذه الوثائق المتعلقة بـ 9
11 ، فلن يكون موضع ترحيب عند نقطة
الصفر ومواقع النصب التذكارية الأخرى هذه ،
لكن الرئيس قال إن
911  كانت العائلات دائمًا في
قلبه وأن أصواتهم وبصيرةهم
كانت موضع تقدير في ر
تتطلب عمليته الآن هذا الأمر التنفيذي
أن يتم الإفراج عن أي عناصر تم رفع السرية عنها في
غضون الأشهر الستة المقبلة الآن
كما في الذكرى العشرين لتاريخ 11 سبتمبر ، سيكون
الرئيس باراك أوباما
والسيدة الأولى السابقة ميشيل أوباما
في متناول اليد أيضًا في مدينة نيويورك
الرئيس السابق جورج دبليو بوش سيتحدث
في شانكسفيل بنسلفانيا نائب
الرئيس كامالا هاريس ستحضر أيضًا
حدثًا في شانكسفيل قبل
الانضمام إلى بادينز يوم السبت في
البنتاغون حيث تتوحد البلاد حول
هذه اللحظة في يوم رسمي
لإحياء ذكرى الآلاف من  الأشخاص
الذين لقوا حتفهم في تلك الهجمات على
11 سبتمبر علامات آرليت سي إن ويلمنجتون ديلاوير